recently a slippage of the 9900 K
assuring it being able to have an all
core overclock to 5.5 you Hertz on just
water and results are quite spectacular
[Music]
welcome to Horace hobbies so a lot of
people including myself were very
skeptical about 97 arcade because well
the core count was increasing there
completely removing the function
hyper-threading so we actually had less
threatened 8700 K at 8 cores main
threats instead of six codes in 12
threads but in tow has definitely
significantly ramped up to speed which
has not only match the performance of a
diesel arcade but exceeded it
take a look at the Cinebench compared to
other CPUs it got 254 single thread in
1827 for multi thread that's a lot
higher than a decent arcade and even
higher than 27 X now those other CPUs
are not overclocked because if there
were we would probably see scores in
1904 the 27 X and 1640 8700 K but even
despite that the performance of the 19
motorcades were wildly impressive
because you have to remember that the 97
arcade only has half the number of
threads as 27 X these high over clocks
may be a result of enjoy using solder
get online generation but again it is
too early to confirm anything right now
now there are also some rich prices as
well for these CPUs however these are
almost certainly just placeholders
because the 97k was priced at 561 euros
with be 80
now that's around $650 and you can
actually get an 8 core 1630 CPU from
until the 78 20x for almost $200 cheaper
at four hundred and seventy dollars so
it really makes no sense at all it will
most likely be the same MSRP as the 87
our decay may be a little bit higher so
pretty much the upper three hundreds a
price higher and that really just
doesn't make sense
it's at that point it would just make
more sense to get the 7820 X a stock 78
20x performed almost the same as that
overclocked 97 or decay so that point 78
could be the clear option the same
retailer leaked a date as well
it says expected stock date is September
7 to 2018 however this doesn't align
with any other rumors and doesn't mass
release date of October last year
so what video carts are suggesting is
that this is merely the date that they
are going to receiving stock of the
ninth-generation CPUs from Intel but the
CPUs themselves won't actually launch
till October we also see a 97 K running
on a-z 370 motherboard and if that is
true it's really nice to see that in
toast finally implementing some
backwards compatibility again I'm not
really sure Age 3 10 boards are
supported but really if you're getting
manage number K you should least get a Z
370 motherboard so what exactly this is
all mean
well the 92 Mary Kay is about equal with
the 27 X in terms of multi performance
but it's significantly higher in signal
to high performance so what that would
mean is that it will completely beat the
range of our X in terms of gaming
performance and people focused on just
gaming would definitely go for the 97 K
over the 2700 X and a plus point is that
the 97k won't be too much more expensive
in the twenty-seventh of X we will
probably see the same price gap as we're
seeing right now with the eighties 100 K
and 22 our X but then again you won't be
getting a good stock CPU cooler and you
won't be able to overclock with
lower-level boards that is something to
keep in mind as well also this may lead
to AMD launching the 2800 X which should
pretty much be identical with 2200 X but
be able to overclock to 4.5 years or
more
now the 97 K is not going to even come
close to fighting with Verizon in terms
of value Ryan's is definitely still the
clear winner in terms of that however
9:7 arcade does seem to be a monster in
terms of gaming performance and it will
most likely claim the crown from the 80s
and arcade as the best gaming CPU
available on the market so if you're
considering the 87 RK
then you may want to wait but that's
just what I think what do you guys think
do you think amy is actually going to
bring our 2800 X and what do you think
about the 99 hurricane make sure comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video
measured up like and consider
subscribing if we'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]